you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
labor pledges a huge increase in climate
spending promising 28 billion pounds a
year in extra cash to help turn the uk
economy green
on the verge of government germany's
green party emerges as the king maker
after finishing third in the bundestag
election
and not giving up yet insulated britain
protesters target heathrow in a return
to the m25 and the breach of a high
court injunction
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now labour has promised to invest tens
of billions of pounds more every year to
help protect the uk from climate change
and turn the country's economy green
that pledge which was made by the shadow
chancellor rachel reeves and was
immediately welcomed by environmental
groups would quadruple the amount
currently spent by the government and
throws down the gauntlet to the
conservatives ahead of their party
conference and cop 26.
i can announce today
labour's climate investment pledge
an additional 28 billion pounds of
capital investment in our country's
green transition for each and every year
of this decade
i will be a responsible chancellor i
will be britain's first green chancellor
well let's take a look at labour's
10-year plan in more detail then and the
party has promised to invest in the
green industries of the future now that
means more gigafactories to build
batteries for electric vehicles
also more money for the offshore wind
sector with labour saying that it would
make sure that turbines are made in
britain there'd also be a focus on green
jobs and labour has promised to support
workers through the green transition and
retrain them for low-carbon jobs
and the party has pledged to invest up
to 3 billion pounds to decarbonize the
uk steel industry
well the steel industry decarbonization
plans were announced at conference by
the shadow business secretary ed
miliband who i spoke to earlier i began
by asking him how affordable labour's
green investment pledge is
it is absolutely affordable and you know
the unaffordable choice is not to invest
because if we don't invest in tackling
the climate crisis we will store up
massive costs for the future for future
generations as they have to cope with
the appalling consequences of climate
change and if we do make these
investments and i was talking about this
yesterday in relation to the steel
industry it can create hundreds of
thousands if not millions of jobs across
our country
in helping to to build the economy of
the future in our manufacturing industry
in creating the green spaces that we
need retrofitting and insulating homes
this is about the economy of the future
it's absolutely the right thing to do
it's what joe biden president biden is
seeking to do in the united states i
think it's a bold imaginative and really
important move that rachel reeves has
announced today well let's talk a little
bit more about the money because
yesterday you announced three billion
pounds for the steel industry to
decarbonize that particular industry
which may be great for the planet but
there is a price to pay isn't there
people already facing higher taxes under
labour they'd have to go up even more
wouldn't they
well no what we're saying is it's right
to borrow to invest so take the steel
industry really important industry it's
a strategic industry for our national
security it's the foundation of our
manufacturing industry the best
estimates are it will cost six billion
to make this industry a green industry
because at the moment it's responsible
for more than 10
of our manufacturing emissions now we
could decide not to have a steel
industry which means that tens of
thousands of people will lose their jobs
all we can decide as the choice labor's
made to do a partnership with the
private sector to invest for the future
as other countries are doing and we can
have a clean green steel industry and i
think that's the right choice it's the
right choice for our communities it's
the right choice for our economy and it
means we don't end up relying on
imported steel from countries like china
but ultimately we will have to pay for
it and also it can't happen overnight
can it decarbonizing a whole industry
may be the right thing to do but we have
to take it very delicately the same as
transitioning out of fossil fuel
industries or jobs will go there are so
many jobs tied up in these industries
well you are right about that definitely
and you know i think what's important
from labor
this week is it's about a plan for the
future it's about a long-term plan
and goodness knows when we see some of
the chaos that this government is
presiding over our country needs a
long-term plan you're right it's not
going to happen overnight it's a
decade-long plan it's a decade-long plan
that rachel reeves has announced today
it's the same that i had announced
yesterday
in relation to steel to the steel
industry and it's about working with
business we have many great businesses
in our country and that you know what
they're crying out for i see this as
shadow business and energy secretaries
they're crying out for a sense of a plan
they're crying out for a sense of a
framework and a sense of certainty and
that's what labour is providing ed
miliband thanks very much indeed
thank you
and you can watch my full interview with
ed miliband including his thoughts on
the government's planning for cop 26 on
our youtube channel
now at one point during the german
election campaign the green party was
leading the polls now with that in mind
you may have thought that yesterday's
vote in which the greens finished third
would have been a disappointment but
germany's political system means that
along with the liberal free democratic
party they're all but certain to be king
makers in the new government now the
center left sdp spd won the largest
share of with around 26 of the votes now
the party managed to edge out the cdu
that's angela merkel's party which ended
up on 24 percent and that means that
either the spd or the cdu would need to
form a coalition in order to take office
and it's all but certain that one of
them will form that coalition with both
annalena bearbox green party and the fdp
led by christian lintner which came in
fourth now it would either be what's
become known as the traffic light
coalition because of the party colours
with the spd's leader olaf schultz or
the jamaica coalition that's green black
and yellow with the cdu's candidate
armin lachette
well our euro correspondent adam parsons
is in berlin for us so adam is it
inevitable that the greens will make up
part of the coalition and if so what
impact might that have on germany's
green direction
i think it is pretty much certain
that the greens are going to be part of
a coalition and they will use that to
try and exert
influence as you said this is going to
be a protracted bout
of horse trading i think both the sbd
and the cdu those two big parties are
going to do everything they can to woo
the greens into coalition and that will
involve offering them seats already a
suggestion that those might involve uh
an elena burbot maybe going to the
foreign ministry uh and the other green
leader robert habback uh tonight rumors
that he might be offered the the
position as vice chancellor so these are
serious concessions but it's going to be
difficult because it will also involve
as you said the fdp but we often refer
to as liberals actually they're quite in
some way economic terms quite
conservative they want to see the purse
string has been kept quite tight they
may not want to embrace the greens plans
for considerable expenditure it makes
for a tough round of negotiation but the
greens are right in there and this is
with the reflections of annalina berber
about what sort of government she might
want to see
we made clear that we want real change
we want real fresh wind and each party
now has to make its decision about what
it wants to bring to the government
table and these will be the results that
will present themselves in the coming
days
i think the more natural partnership for
the greens is with the spd but for the
free democrats the ftp is probably more
natural to go in with the cdu and yes
there are a lot of three-letter acronyms
going around at the moment it's all very
uncertain the one thing i think you can
bet on is that this won't happen quickly
there is every chance that come the end
of this year
angela merkel may still be chancellor
and the negotiations might still be
going on
adam thanks very much indeed i'm well
done with those acronyms i think you've
got them all right there thank you
so let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and
australia's prime minister has signaled
he may not attend cop 26 in november as
his government faces criticism from
environmentalists for its poor climate
record in an interview scott morrison
said he hadn't made any final decisions
on attending australia hasn't yet
committed to reaching net zero by 2050
despite the country being the highest
per capita carbon emitter amongst the
world's richest nations
the world's poorest countries have also
said they may not be able to attend cobb
the least developed countries group
expressed concern that delegates from 25
countries may not meet visa requirements
or be able to cover all the quarantine
costs the uk government insists it's
planning to go ahead with a conference
despite calls to postpone it
power cuts to meet government energy use
targets have forced some chinese
factories to shut down and have left
households in the dark china has vowed
to cut energy intensity by around three
percent in 2021 to help meet its climate
goals although only 10 of 30 mainland
regions managed to meet the targets in
the first half of the year
now insulate britain climate protesters
don't appear to be giving up without a
fight when the government obtained a
high court injunction last week banning
them from blocking the m25 they turned
their attention to the port of dover but
today 53 demonstrators were arrested
after they returned to the m25 in breach
of that injunction and blocked an
approach to heathrow sky's sherman
freeman powell was there
8 o'clock on monday morning
this junction on the m25 would usually
see thousands of motorists
but today insulate britain back in town
determined to cause disruption
it's the sixth time in just two weeks
they've pulled this stunt everything
else has been tried
but this time the police have had enough
arresting 53 people over the course of a
few hours and trying to prevent the
chaos it comes after an injunction was
granted to national highways last week
but that didn't seem to discourage them
the protesters out here today are
risking their freedom as breaking a high
court injunction comes at a cost but the
protesters say they're more afraid of
climate change than they are of jail and
will continue doing these protests until
they think the government has heard them
i'm 44 from dorset and i'm a scientist
i'm risking losing
everything i have like my like
financially like friends um my career
my liberty i'm risking going to prison
today and that's how strongly i feel
about this and there's many of us here
there's over 40 of us here today and
we're not going to be deterred by
injunctions whatever they throw at us
because this problem is more serious
what's coming is more serious
the message from insulate britain is
clear they want the government to
insulate british homes starting with
social housing by 2025.
the governments are also clear they want
to stop the disruption
starting now
sherman freeman powell sky news
we'll do stay with us coming up after
the break i'll be joined by jen allen
lecturer at cardiff university and mike
berners-lee a leading expert on carbon
footprinting they're standing by we're
going to be discussing if cop 26 can be
a success without the australian prime
minister and how important is individual
sustainability that's coming up
[Music]
luke got furloughed he was my husband
around about the end of last year
october november time
and
within that time frame he developed a
gambling disorder
i didn't know about any of this until
luke had sadly taken his own life um
three weeks later i received his phone
and i was able to log into certain
things and slowly i then started to get
a picture of what had happened and he
had developed that gambling disorder
like i said
um
looking further into his accounts
three bets had been dropping in at times
when he'd put money in and he'd lost it
it lost quite a lot of money and then a
free bet went in and then luke would
then
get another loan
put that in lose it
the money had gone another free bet
would go in and it kind of developed and
just progressed basically until he he
lost control and he just couldn't take
it anymore
it was so difficult because that first
three weeks of him passing away um
obviously when someone takes their own
life you do question yourself you think
well you know what did i do the kids
were doing the same thing we've got two
children together um his family were all
questioning what we'd done what would
happen
and it wasn't it was literally when we
got his phone back
the police gave me his phone and i was
able to log into certain accounts his
paypal
the money was going from paypal into
into gambling accounts i don't look at
the money situation to be fair because
he lost his life it was a lot of money
um it was it was not affordable and it
was why he was he was funding it with
lions because he he couldn't afford it
it wasn't something he could
use his wages on gambling is a really
harmful product it's addictive it's more
addictive than and class a drugs such as
heroin and you can lose everything
within minutes um
so yeah the three bets it's an
inducement that is just so unnecessary
um
i feel like they they they just
shouldn't be available i mean luckily
i've i've been really looked after by a
charity called gambling with lives they
have been amazing and they have really
taken care of me every day is hard and
every day i'm going to have to live with
the fact that he's no longer here
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
tuesday will start dry through some
central and eastern part but heavy
showers spreading up from the southwest
will merge together to give some more
persistent rain for many central areas
parts of northern scotland parts of the
southeast will stay dry through the day
but it's going to be cooler still with a
top temperature of around 17 degrees
celsius 63 degrees fahrenheit and
certainly the afternoon is looking very
wet and very windy with localized scales
so once again air pollution levels are
likely to be low right across the
country
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
and welcome back to the daily climate
show on sky news and we're getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day now with jen allen
lecturer at cardiff university and lead
expert of carbon footprinting and
professor at lancaster university mike
berners-lee so welcome to both of you
good to see you here tonight
now then the australian prime minister
scott morrison has said he's yet to
decide whether he'll be attending cop 26
the un climate change conference in
november and he joins the likes of
china's president xi jinping who's also
yet to confirm if he'll be attending the
summit in glasgow so without leaders of
the world's biggest countries how much
could the summit achieve well let's
discuss this now mike lee to you first
of all does it really matter if the
likes of scott morrison or xi jinping
are actually there in person they'll
have delegations in glasgow won't they
do do you need the people themselves
there
well possibly not quite necessarily but
it's an important opportunity to send
out a message about how much you care
about this huge issue and you know here
we are in a climate emergency
and just to be clear you know nobody
anyone should be giving any time of day
to any politician that doesn't take
climate really really seriously uh and
show coherent uh policies uh that
demonstrate
that they mean it um and at least of all
voting for them so you know i think it's
sending out certainly um the wrong
message for sure
generally do you agree with that i mean
how important do you think it is
symbolically that leaders are actually
there having face-to-face meetings
they're there in person
it's actually fairly rare that
uh
we will see heads of state
show up at a climate meeting and
sometimes they've been pretty
counterproductive
so maybe conversely this shows that
they have to deny the invitation
so it shows that cop is a chance to put
public pressure and political pressure
on leaders and so maybe that function of
cop is actually working because we're
talking about these major emitters that
may not send their leaders we still need
their pledges to be updated but you know
that could be an email
well that's interesting and in fact as
you say it's it's not just about turning
up it's what's decided there isn't it
let's take a look at what the un head
has said that he said either we're
united or we're doomed so what do you
think mike
it's not just about persuading world
leaders to turn up it's getting
consensus when they're there so so how
do you do that
well i mean the
quote you've just given sums up the big
picture on what the situation we've got
now so either
our humanity is going to learn to
cooperate at the global level
quickly far better than it's ever done
before
uh or it's pretty clear that we're going
to head to a pretty dark place in the in
the in the reasonably near future so
that is the you know that's the um
that's the sort of top line of it so how
do we get about that cooperation one of
the things is we we need to find a way
of this working for every for everyone
and and all states and one of the things
that would be really helpful to
uh to give the cop its best chance would
be to sending at least be sending out
messages that we care about each other
and that we and that we cooperate so for
example how we deal with the vaccines in
the pandemic um you know would be one
way that we could be sending out
messages that we are capable of of
looking out for each other and coming to
arrangements that everyone can live with
at the end of the day we're almost
certainly going to need a carbon price
to keep the fuel in the ground and
somehow that price needs to be
implemented in such a way that as i say
everybody can live with it do you think
that's right some kind of carbon price
do we need some kind of stick as well as
a carrot to get consensus do you think
at cop26 jen
is that important that's the way to go
there's very few sticks in global
cooperation i'm afraid
i think we need to start looking beyond
cop26 and what we're seeing is climate
being woven into other areas of global
cooperation like security announcements
that were made recently
so we can start realizing that
just like the pandemic has influenced so
many parts of our lives climate change
is going to do the same thing and it's
going to touch on many areas of
cooperation at the global level
and we're going to start building
incentives to act on climate
into trade agreements into security
agreements into humanitarian and food
related agreements and that will
increase the pressure to act on climate
because if we don't then all of those
other agreements will start to fail okay
let's move on to our next subject now
shall we because the energy and supply
crisis has once again demonstrated how
easy it is for our lives to be disrupted
by hitches in the supply chain so is
consumer behavior part of the solution
and would living more sustainably help
resolve those big international supply
and chain issues jen to you first of all
so we are experiencing various supply
issues so is there a green root out of
this and is there a way that consumers
can help themselves
i think consumers are going to have to
get used to this
uh global supply chains are only as
strong as the weakest link they're a
chain like anything else and climate
change is going to lead to extreme
weather events droughts and other
shortages
so it might not be that we can green our
way out of this
or that consumers will just learn to do
better it's that we're going to have to
learn to be more resilient and we're
going to have to learn to deal with
shortages popping up
do you agree mike that we've just got to
get our heads around it or is there
something that we can do i mean everyone
talks about shopping locally i know
there's one interesting statistic local
deliveries emit less than half as much
co2 per item than online only retailers
so can we take actions that will help
ourselves
well it's a bit of both and there's
definitely things that we can do
uh
as individuals and as a society to
alleviate some of the problems that
jen's talking about so for example you
know the less energy we need to consume
the less we're going to be reliant
on energy sources some of which might
come from other countries you know the
more of our own food
we can produce ourselves the less will
be interrupted by by supply chain uh
problems and you know the less we get
through
uh you know tons of material goods um
we you know we take some of the pressure
off the system and but there's no doubt
that you know we need to change the way
we live quite a bit most of the time we
can do that in a way which if we're
smart about it we can actually use it as
an opportunity to improve the quality of
our lives not it's not like a wearing a
hair shirt but we do need to be
when we change habits a bit yeah jenna
just a quick thought on that it's got to
be in people's interests hasn't it
because globalization is out there
there's no putting that back in the tin
is is there do people need to be
motivated in some way to do the right
thing
i think people need to be motivated but
i think we also have to realize that
everything mike was just talking about
is a systemic change
it's dealing with how we grow our food
how we move goods around the world how
we produce how we consume and that goes
beyond what an individual can do in
their own personal lives it doesn't mean
we're powerless and there's always
things that we can do okay it does mean
that we still have to keep thinking
about how we can systematically tackle
the climate crisis okay in a way that
will be green and productive we must
leave it there i'm afraid i can see
nodding though mike berners-lee thanks
very much indeed and jen allen thanks to
you as well
well that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show i'm going to be
joined by dr cece who from the
university of oxford's environmental
change institute and the environmental
consultant richard black but do stay
with us at sky news tonight is up next
with all the top stories with derma man
and do stay with us
[Music]